why would you want someone that's super
ripped but they're so serious all the
time
but what about what about that um you
know what is the case then because like
you know in London they've got like
Magic Mike or whatever it is you know
that the thing that Channing Tatum was
in and there's a picture of those guys
with you know the rips and everything I
mean girls often when they go to that I
say oh it's just a laugh it's just me
and my mates you know but is it really
or is it just like the girls who go to
that they're just like these you know
they're like is it a serious Turner or
not and if it's not then why are you
guys all saying body's not that
important
because
foreign